carlos has taken an initial dose of a
prescription medication the relationship
between the time between the elapsed
time T in hours since he took the first
dose and the amount of medication M of T
in milligrams in his bloodstream is
modeled by the following function all
right and how many hours will Carlos
have one milligram of medication
remaining in his bloodstream so M of
what T is equal to so we need
essentially solve for M of T is equal to
1 milligram because M of T outputs
whatever value it outputs is going to be
in milligram so let's just solve that so
M of T is they give us a definition its
model is an exponential function 20
times e to the negative 0.8 T is equal
to 1 so let's see we can divide both
sides by 20 and so we will get e to the
negative 0.8 T is equal to 1 over 21
over 20 which we could write as 0.05
0.05 I'm feeling we have to deal with
decimals here regardless and so how do
we how do we solve this well one way to
think about it one way to think about if
we took what happens if we took the
natural log of both sides and just
remember the a reminder the natural log
is the logarithm base e so actually let
me write this let me write this a little
bit differently so this is zero that is
0.05 so I'm going to take the natural
log of both sides so Ln Ln so the
natural log this says what power do I
have to raise e to to get to e to the
negative zero point eight T well I've
got to raise e to the this this
simplifies to negative zero point eight
T once again natural log this thing let
me clarify Ln of e to the negative zero
point eight T this is equivalent to if I
were to write log base e of e
to the negative 0.8 t what power would
have to raise e to to get to e to the
negative zero point eighty we have to
raise it to the negative 0.8 T power so
that's why the left hand side simplified
to this and that's going to be equal to
the natural log actually I'll just leave
it in those terms the natural log of
0.05 natural log of 0.05 all of that and
now we can divide both sides by negative
0.8 to solve for T so let's do that so
we divide by negative 0.8 divided by
negative 0.8 and so T is going to be
equal to all of this business on the
left hand side now we just have a T on
the right hand side we have all of this
business which I think a calculator will
be valuable for so let me get a
calculator out clear it out and let's
start with 0.05 let's take the natural
log that's that button right over there
the natural log we get that value and we
want to divide by negative 0.8 so
divided by divided by 0.8 negative so
we're going to divide by 0.8 negative is
equal to let's see they want us to round
to the nearest hundredth so three point
seven four so it'll take three point
seven four seven four hours for his
dosage to go down to one milligram
where it actually started it 20
milligrams when T equals zero it's 20
after three point seven four hours he's
at down in his bloodstream to 1
milligram I guess his body has
metabolized the rest of it in some way